this is Central Park it's an iconic part
of New York City
a piece of nature tucked inside
Manhattan if you've lived in New York or
even visited you've probably been here
but there's a part of this land story
that visitors will never see it's the
story of what was here before the park
and the community that was destroyed to
make way for it
in the 1820s New York City looked like
this most people lived in this area
lower Manhattan
pretty much everything above it was yet
to be settled in this map you can see
how different the geography was these
little lines illustrate what used to be
hills in Manhattan
this was the countryside downtown was
the opposite lower Manhattan was dense
and crowded a few small neighborhoods
were home to many of the city's poor
whites and immigrants and also too much
of its black population this document
shows the number of slaves in New York
State you can see how it went down
gradually from 20,000 and 1,800 to
10,000 in 1820 and finally to just 75 in
1830 that's because in New York slavery
wasn't abolished all at once instead it
was ended over about 30 years and as
more free black people joined the
workforce racial tensions rose the
people who were enslaved were now in
competition with people coming over for
jobs that tension led to violence and
lower Manhattan became increasingly
dangerous for free black people then in
1825 plots of land started to go up for
sale here
uptown it was a way out a black man
named Andrew Williams decided to buy
three Lots you know word gets out black
people seeing other black people and
saying oh there's a little bit of a
community developing here maybe we can
just fold into this community so they
start to move in after Williams more
Lots filled up with black families and
churches and it was here between 82nd
and 89th Street that the community of
Seneca village was born moving up to
Seneca village offered black families an
affordable safe place it also gave them
the chance to vote black men could only
vote in New York if they owned property
over the course of the next three
decades the community grew to nearly 300
residents records from the census show
that they were laborers domestic workers
waiters
and shoemakers and they built dozens of
homes three churches and a school for
black students later when Irish and
German immigrants started moving into
Seneca village it became unique for
another reason it was an integrated
community it seems that people of all
ethnicities were likely getting along
based on the church records that were
here among the documents are evidence
that some white and black families
attended baptisms together were buried
next to each other in the same cemetery
and intermarried the people who lived in
this area were individuals who were
trying to find a new way of life over
the next three decades the population of
New York City nearly quadrupled lower
Manhattan could no longer hold everyone
the city's white elite were worried that
the entire island would be consumed by
development they said it called for the
necessity of a city park to give lungs
to the city this came out of the elite
being able to start to travel to Europe
and they see the sean's Elysee and they
see Kensington Park and they think that
the city deserves to have a park of that
stature on July 21st 1853 New York set
aside 750 acres of land to create
America's first major landscaped public
park the Central Park but the proposed
area for the park included Seneca
Village along with thousands of other
lots of land home to about 1600 people
in order to facilitate the perks
development the city's newspaper started
to downplay who really lived there they
really described these people as living
in shanties and shacks people of debase
cultures were living off the land but
that wasn't true in 2011 Cynthia and a
team of archaeologists excavated in the
former Seneca village site they came
away with 250 bags of objects to analyze
which now live here in New York City's
archeological repository these objects
suggests that Seneca village was
wealthier than many assumed when we
compared the objects from the homes of
the people in Seneca Village with
artifacts from Greenwich Village an
elite upper middle-class neighborhood in
some cases they were using the same kind
of iron stone plate within what was
called the Gothic pattern quite a few
pieces of porcelain in Seneca village
and porcelain wasn't expensive where
they also found other objects like a
comb a smoking pipe roasting pan and
part of a toothbrush that probably
didn't belong to poor people
toothbrushes were not common among the
working class as well as a middle class
until around 1920 and the artifacts
themselves were only one part of their
analysis for example from the census
records from 1855 we know that there was
a very high level of education getting a
high school education was clearly an
important factor in the community and
that's very much a part of middle-class
identity the findings indicate that
Seneca village wasn't a shanty town it
was a working and middle-class community
a growing neighborhood of black property
owners and an experiment in integration
but to the white New York elite of 1856
it wasn't worth saving
a July 1856 article in The New York
Times referred to it with a slur the
ebon inhabitants after whom the village
is called have been notified to remove
by the first of August
many residents fought to keep their land
by filing objections to their forced
removal but Seneca village along with
the other settlements on the land for
Central Park was seized and destroyed in
their place the city made pathways built
bridges and arches and planted thousands
of trees Central Park was done and
Seneca village was gone forever we can't
imagine New York City without Central
Park but I'm I'm finally grateful that
the recognition of the Prix Park history
has emerged today New York is starting
to reckon with this part of its history
an exhibition with information about
Seneca village is temporarily up in the
park but the real legacy of Seneca
village is a story that's repeated
itself again and again in cities
everywhere land property ownership
that's how you get wealth and you pass
wealth on from generation to generation
but you're getting a bulldozer that
comes through because a new highway has
to come through or a new hospital or
development site has to come in Seneca
village was no different
it's time that we own it and we come to
recognize that there are these great
stories that live beneath the surface of
the park it's not just african-american
history it's just American history
[Music]